what up what up it's turbo Mr run that
back turbo and I want you to check me
out right now on the bootleg C podcast
hey before we get into the interview we
want to give a shout out to our family
over at Imperial extraction they're
bringing you today's episode um and
check this out if you want a free 2 G
thca loaded pre-roll yes that's right
you can get one of these for free you
don't have to buy anything all you got
to do is go to Imperial extraction.
comom use the promo code bootleg and
they're going to send you one of these
for free look
premium glass tip one more time Imperial
extraction. comom promo code bootleg
you're going to get a free 2 G THC
Diamond loaded pre-roll that's 1 and 12
gram of that premium top shell flow and
a half a gram of THC diamonds loaded up
to your door for free just pay shipping
let's get into the
interview yo Bole Kev show man we got a
special guest in here his name is Turbo
you might know him uh you heard his tag
on all these damn big records uh one of
the biggest producers in the game is
here welcome thank you bro thank you yes
sir how's the first of all man uh I know
uh you're one of the very few artists
who could say they have a diamond single
yep and I didn't even realize drip too
hard was Diamond like Ace was like make
sure you bring up the fact he's got a
diamond record and I was like is drip
too hard Diamond damn sure is that [__]
is crazy yeah that's got to feel crazy
cuz that that's not there's not that
many people who could have that on the
resume these days bro that's like
Michael Jackson [__] you know what
that's 10 platinum records yeah if you
don't know yeah no yeah it do feel crazy
I mean I guess it's just a blessing bro
like I can't I can't call it anything
else you know what was your kind of like
uh cuz I I guess that's kind of the
project that we kind of like you became
more like a household name in hip-hop
that tag of yours kind of give me a
little breakdown on like your come up as
a producer
in Atlanta cuz it is a very
very um flooded Marketplace for
producers these days and it's hard to
break through it's hard to get
placements so kind of give me like a
rundown like how you started producing
and like just your come up well I I
started engineering so um engineering
was like I got fired from my job and
that became my job you know what I mean
and that's how I was hustling and making
money but I always had the passion to be
a producer engineering was literally
just how I how I ate you know from day
to day but that's also how I met all the
artists and at that time Atlanta was a
place it still is but it was even more
of a place where we just embraced
everybody so if you was from Atlanta and
you knew you know such and such or you
went to high school or such and such you
had an opportunity to get inside the
studio if you knew what you was doing so
I took so many of those opportunities
just friends and people that I grew up
with like you know I record you for free
I got beats for free uh [__] I'll sit
here all night for free you know what I
mean whatever it is and I just slowly
just started they gave you an inch and
you took a foot I I took I took like
three feet you know what I mean people
don't even know like even um like the
metro and 21 Savage album I recorded
most of that oh that's crazy yeah I
recorded most of that and know even like
X [__] I recorded that that was like my
engineer career and then when Gunner
kind of started getting his traction
that was the first person that was just
rapping on my Beats and we did okay and
drip season three together and all that
stuff and that's when it was like okay
turbo not a he's not an engineer he's a
producer yeah a lot of people who don't
know like first of all it's if you're a
producer or an artist to have the
ability to be an engineer as well yeah
it's such a nice way to just get in the
door yeah for sure like I can record you
you know what I'm saying or you can
record yourself you know what I mean
like save some money but like so many
dope producers and artists I know they
started off as the guy in the studio
that no one really pays attention to
that's running the pro pro tools
the and like also if you're a good
engineer you lowkey are doing some sort
of production too on that [__] record
cuz you're you're you're dropping [__]
out you're you might put some effects on
some [__] like so that's dope like if
you're an engineer out there that's why
I tell all my homies like my my my guy
who runs my uh Studio here um he's my
engineer but he's also a producer and a
songwriter yeah you got to do both these
days you got to do damn near three
things these days just to even cut
through you had to just bring value to
the table man Super Value and be
consistent for sure damn so you were in
the studio so for you like were you was
it like a thing where everyone knew you
made beats or did you not want to like
be the guy who's the engineer who's also
hey by the way yo I got some beats you
know there's that guy I was that guy
okay you were that guy but you had some
heat so there's a difference you yeah
it's like oh this I'm the engineer that
got some [__] you know what I mean and
it's like oh call him back tomorrow and
call him back you know you can call me
in an hour and I'm gonna be there in an
hour you know what I mean it's not it's
not no Bouie [__] you know what I mean
is it like cuz I always say that about
Atlanta is it feels like a much more I
wouldn't say easy but it feels like more
of a
community in terms of the music side cuz
being in La I feel like everybody's real
like stingy with the connect stingy with
just everything with their energy I feel
like in Atlanta it feels like more like
I mean I've gone to Atlanta Studio
sessions and everyone's just hanging out
like people could just pull up like is
do you do you feel that difference now
that you're I'm sure you're going to La
sessions or you're the mix more in
different places is it nothing like
Atlanta yeah it's nothing like home it's
nothing like the South you know what I
mean but especially Atlanta that's a
place where like you you you know to
embrace whoever's coming up you know to
embrace Atlanta you know to [__] with
the younger guys you know what I mean
that's in that's part of the culture it
wasn't until I started traveling that it
was like oh I'm not supposed to tell you
you know like you know this guy or
introduce you to get this guy is like
that's y'all don't do that type of [__]
like I do that [__] all the time you
know what I mean it's almost in the DNA
of that City to like like be on the cuz
I mean Atlanta's had the culture for 20
25 years now yeah face so it's almost
like it's the most Atlanta [__] ever to
break artists cuz any of the hot new
shit's always coming out of the South
it's very seldomly it'll be out of New
York or it'll be out of La so it's
almost like that's kind of what y'all do
yeah you got to make your stop in
Atlanta you got to spend some months in
Atlanta and and run through those
Studios and see what that feel like
defit do you feel like that's something
cuz we always have these conversations
about La artists not breaking through
cuz there's some really dope talented La
artists that um for whatever reason like
get to a certain point and then they
have a hard time kind of getting over
the hill in terms of like maybe being
hot in the South or in the East or
whatever do you feel like cuz like a guy
like uh we got a homie Kaylin for real
for real who he went out to Atlanta for
like a year and just cooked hung out
with
DJs and I feel like that's important for
anybody like you said no matter where
you're from you could be from [__]
Indianapolis
you from wherever you got to go spend
some time in the a yeah facts I mean I
know kin too
um yeah I mean I I don't I don't know
what it is but you have to stop through
there it's like how La used to be you
know what I mean and everybody had to
come to La for some type of reason you
got to go to Atlanta to to feel that
culture M got to I don't know what I
don't know what it is know yeah go have
some uh some wings of the blue flame for
God's sake yeah some chicken or some
[__] like that what's the strip club out
that I had uh I had uh they they play uh
some shitty music but they got good lamb
chops um cheetah yes yeah yes yeah
that's the GTA Strip they got the they
got the Nickelback plan yeah food good
as a [__] they got Metallica
Nickelback cre and [__] the food they
done kind of updated it a little more
you know what I'm saying a a little bit
but yeah that's the place where you go
and eat at and and throw $ one1 Dollar
at a time one at a time yeah you fold it
up you just slide on yeah it's the the
real GTA that's for you yeah uh you got
your own holiday in Fon County yep turbo
day yep that's got to be [__] sweet
man it's incredible like what happens
that like what like we see that
happening but like what what comes with
that anything cool I mean we're
organizing right now um the turbo Day
July 8th it's just really like a a
opportunity for me to just just do stuff
for like the kids in the community so
you kind of turn that into opportunity
to help Community yeah you know what I
mean give it give it a actual time and
place instead of it you know me coming
for a memorial day or something like
that and trying to do something or
compete so for Thanksgiving or yeah you
know Turkey driving all that stuff I did
turkey drives this year too but with
your own day is like it came about I was
trying to do something for the community
but you needed like permits and all of
this stuff to to take over like the
parks and stuff down there you can't
just do it and um I got to working with
the city and we just couldn't knock out
last year and they gave me a day just
for even trying and trying to really
like make it happen cuz nobody does
anything on that side and that just be
easier to just do it this year you know
I already know who the right people to
call and how to organize everything so
it's it's for me it's just a way to show
the kids this is something this is this
is what you do once you get to this
place and Inspire these kids cuz it was
nobody that was doing that when I was
young hey let's stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at my
book damn it all right look NFL playoffs
are going down Super Bowl's on the way
go to my bookie right now and let's get
in on the action not to mention right
now is the time to sign up all right if
you sign up with the promo code bootleg
ATM mybookie.ag head over there right
now you're going to get your um first
deposit bonus up to
$1,000 all right that means you put in
that promo code you put in your money
they're going to match it they're going
to get you right up to
$11,000 um and uh I don't care what
you're into same game parlays uh I don't
care if you want to get down with the uh
uh over unders you know what I'm saying
some of the prop bets whatever it is my
bookie is going to get you situated all
right so go to
mybookie.ag get in on this action all
right I just hit a crazy they got this
thing where you could put three teams on
a teaser and they give you plus 13 if
it's a three-leg teaser woo look do that
tomorrow do that next weekend on these
NFL games trust me if you know what
you're doing you should be able to hit
that all right pretty good odds on it
too all right so go to mybookie.ag sign
up with the promo code bootleg and get
that first deposit bonus up to $1,000
right now also want to give a shout out
to our folks at bluechew listen man it's
getting cold outside it's cold as hell
outside out here in LA right now you see
me I got the jacket on it's cold it's
cuffing season all right if you got a
rectile dysfunction uh if you're dealing
with stress at work if your dick ain't
[__] it's all good blue got you all
right let me tell you about blue Chu a
lot of people always are asking me does
Blu work yes it works like a charm all
right go to blu.com use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up and they're
going to show you that it works because
they're going to send you a month for
free that's right a month supply of Blu
for free all you got to do is pay $5
shipping all right blu.com use the promo
code bootleg same active ingredient as
Viagra and Calis but it comes in a
chewable form and it's delivered right
to your door in a very discreet
packaging you don't have to go to the
doctors anymore to talk about why your
dicks you know underperforming you know
and look I'mma Be Honest the blue Chu is
kind of like you know when Barry Bonds
hit 70 home runs hey look bro if you
want to impress abroad get you a blue
you go all night bro you're dick ain't
never been harder blu.com promo code
bootleg get a free month supply right
now all right all you got to do is pay
shipping let's get back to the interview
what is uh for people who are watching
this maybe some kids who are watching
this who are trying to figure out the
production game what is your layout are
you using Pro Tools are you using Fruity
Loops like what is your production
interface your go-to that's some
exclusive [__] but I'm I'mma tell you
you know what I mean but um I use a a
number of things so it could be a little
bit of Ableton for my Melodies and into
FL and I mix it in Protools or I I
reverse it and you know if we going
through the through the keyboards I'm
recording in Protools and taking it to
to FL and cleaning it up in Ableton but
that's like usually my main three those
three yo it's crazy like I feel like
more hip-hop producers should use
Ableton cuz I feel like they don't yeah
cuz Ableton like it's hard to use it
it's very intimidating when you open it
yeah yeah that's the word for sure but
like I feel like cuz i' like I got a
homie in who uses Ableton and he'll show
me things you can do in Ableton and I'm
like why isn't everybody using this this
[__] is crazy this [__] difficult to use
bro no but it looks crazy yeah cuz it
looks different than like Fruity Loops
or protols it's like its own thing and
then they got that Ableton touch with
all the [__] buttons and [__] it's
difficult it's difficult but it's hard
though where do you like do you are you
like actively looking for packs in terms
of your sounds and [__] or are you like
having people send you packs are you
getting Loops are you doing like your
own Loops like give me when you say
packs like what do you mean like like
you got to like your like where you
getting your drums are you finding your
own drums are you are you grab oh uh
yeah kind of like if if it's like a
certain time and I need a certain thing
I'll tweet it out and then like all the
guys will send me
something yeah and I go through them but
I I got a programmer in Atlanta and he
just keep me up to date with all the
newest newest [__] what about on the
loop side cuz that is an entry point for
a lot of up and cominging producers I'm
stepping away from Loops I'm doing my
own Melodies okay it's like the the loop
game is just became
a [__] it's not the loop game anymore
you know what I mean it's like a it's
like a different place and I feel like
it's it's no originality in it yeah for
people who don't know CU it's some
producer geek talk like uh if you're an
up and cominging producer you might send
out hey I'm looking for some Loops yeah
right and so that might be your way in
if you got some fire samples or Loops
that could be your way into getting your
first placement and but then you got
like you said the loop shit's getting so
so uh wash wash down cuz it's cuz there
all these free Loops what's the website
called with all the [__] packs and
splice and there's all this [__] so it's
like I always compare it to like DJing
and Sado like when Sado came yeah like
it made DJing so much easier right you
didn't need to have these turntables
these records and I feel like splice is
like that with producers cuz like you
really don't need to know how to make it
beat all you really got to do is just
line up bars and like you could go on
splice and if you're at least like semi
competent on Pro tools you can you can
get you can get it down you can make a
beat for sure so it's like I just
noticed that like just so much more I'm
like you know we had an artist we were
working with and this kid never made a
beat before and he downloaded a bunch of
[__] on splice and he played a beat and
I was like hey yo who did this he's like
I just did it and I was like you just
did it he's like this the first beat I
ever
made about Jake I was like this [__] is
what's Just Happening like how is this
possible like cuz you know when I was a
kid we had the funck Master Flex video
game on a PlayStation
o MTV gener MTV generate on the first
PlayStation you make beats on the
PlayStation what is that it was fire
heard yeah so there was this MTV beat
making video game on the first
PlayStation and then there was a funk
Flex beat making game on the PS2 that
was
fire like you could like program beats
on this [__] game there was like
actual like some producers who would
like actually like run the PlayStation
into like Pro Tools and take the beats
out of it I never heard of that bro
super fire you should check it out um um
and but it just always seemed like this
super complex process yeah but I feel
like it's just been simplified so much
especially with like you know obviously
fruity Loop's been popular for 20 years
now but for you is it like how hard is
it for you to kind of stay inspired when
there's just so much [__] out there uh
just living living a regular life you
know what I mean um not putting too much
pressure on myself it's not it's not
really
hard because you know back in the day
when it was like all about bands and
stuff like that they literally would
just sit around and jam out right it
wasn't anything like oh we're going to
go and make a beat and so I just try to
live like a regular life and and just
enjoy my day I always say that if I have
a good day then it's just going to pour
out of me right I don't have to smoke
and do all this weird [__] like whatever
um whatever I'm feeling that day and
then I let it be what it's going to be
and I go on to the next day yo s hit
that AC it's getting toasty in here
these lights uh um you don't smoke yeah
yeah I smoke I ain't even mean to but
you don't depend on smoke I don't it's
not like it's not like oh I'm going to
get high as a [__] to go and
make music you know what I mean I can
drip too hard beat I made it on the
computer speakers you know what I mean
oh [__] like falling asleep from leaving
the studio one morning and didn't think
it was going to do anything let me ask
you this cuz your Chemistry with Gunner
is pretty crazy we don't get a lot of uh
you know when I was growing up we had
producers and artists lock the [__] in
like the Rizza and wuang Clan they need
to bring that back Gangstar but DJ
Premier and Guru and but I feel like you
guys are kind of your own version of
that and it's been it's been like that
for a while um how did you initially
meet Gunner we from the same
neighborhood okay so you've known him
for a very long time yeah yeah was he
cuz I always say like between him and
baby over the last like six or seven
years just the like Improvement at just
bars and like actual rapping is like
yeah I don't I'll venture to say we have
never really seen somebody like jump so
far ahead at just the skill of rapping
yeah in a short amount of time did you
always kind of see that in
him um I think in the beginning it was
just it like any producer um you just
want somebody to rap on your [__] so it
we was from the same side we knew each
other we had mutual friends and it was
it was just easy and I knew it was
something different but I can't just say
you know cuzz he's very different for
people like like we're used to the sound
now cuz everyone's taken it done their
own version of what gun and right but
like 7 years ago 6 years ago 5 years ago
it wasn't the sound everybody was like
what the [__] is this yeah so like you
really had to kind of be like man this
shit's different we just going to roll
with it like you I make beats let figure
this out it felt good you know what I
mean it wasn't it wasn't no pressure and
like you know at at that time like
nobody was doing guitars and I loved
acoustic music and he sounded good on
guitars and it just it just worked bro
it was like it was it was a natural
thing it wasn't anything that was for so
even just seeing something different the
only thing I could see different was
we're going to stay in the studio the
longest our work ethics going to it
matches you know what I mean he's not
leaving before me I'm not leaving before
him and it's it's damn near a
competition so early on that's what we
was doing we leaving the studio 7 in the
morning and coming right back at 12 to
the point where like especially those
days right before it popped off I really
remember asking myself what am I doing
this for right you know what I mean I
didn't have much success but I'm like
bro we really going to the studio and we
in the studio all day I don't got no
girl you're putting all this time and
bandwidth into this and you don't even
know if it's going to work out I don't
even know what we're doing this for you
know what I mean it's like why what do
we what do we try I know we're working
on a project and it was drip season 3 at
the time but you know I didn't know why
we was working so hard and um you know I
I mixed drip season 3 and the same night
he was trying to record and I remember
him telling me like cuz I was pissed I'm
like bro I've been mixing this [__]
Alum all day bro like what do you mean
play some beats I don't got no beats you
know what I mean I'm tired I want to
just chill you know what I mean and it's
like bro trust the process bro and uh
you know you know don't burn out and
just play some beat just got to keep
going we F to do it and I'm
like crazy bro got
some
but it but it really was the truth you
know what I'm saying and even comparing
to like some of the producers I came in
with my trajectory has been way
further you know what I mean like it's a
lot of guys I came in with but they have
success you know gold success like you
know I'm not happy unless it's Platinum
right and that became a normal thing but
it it was all about what we was putting
into the music and how much time we were
spending on it so that was like that was
like a good lesson that I was able to
learn with him you know what I mean what
is his writing process like is it is it
cuz you know everybody's got their own I
mean I've been in studio with guys where
other just the beat will play for like
five minutes 10 minutes and they'll just
lay down a bunch of [__] they I like
this part I like this part and then
they'll put it together yeah kind of I
mean he got his own um recording process
but it's it's not like a you know pin
and Pad type of thing it's like a player
beat if it feel good pull it up you
going to do it and we going to do
something else you know what I mean it's
not really a this or that and it's
different time uh have you had any cuz I
I saw an interview you did not too long
ago um because I thought it was dope how
everything happened the way it happened
and you stay stood by your guy and now
now you guys have a number one album A
lot of people say an album of the year
last year snubbed for the Grammy by the
way snub yeah for sure insane yeah
snubbed it happens it's wild it's wild
it happens um but for you have like to
kind of like be that loyal and still be
like yo we're locked in cuz cuz you were
talking to him every day when he was
locked up I saw um has like were other
relationships for you in the music
industry affected by that um I don't
know yet right you know what I mean it's
it's not weird when I'm out and when I'm
doing stuff but I mean I don't know yet
I I always been like a a person that
just stay in the studio and keep to
myself so I was never chummy chummy with
people to the point to where I would
notice like oh this guy's acting
different or this guy's acting different
you're not the guy who's like up in the
mix [__] you're you're about work
yeah you know what I mean I'm not going
to your house party and [__] every day
and you know whatever whatever people do
I I enjoy being in the studio and just
like working and learning new stuff so I
wouldn't say that um it's definitely you
know something to think about when I'm
moving around but most of the time I
forget you know because it's it's
nothing makes sense these days it's I
yeah for sure I always tell people just
like we don't even know what the [__]
really going on right I don't think I
don't think nobody knows what's going on
so it's like you got to be a leader at
this get off the shade R man you know
what I mean um for you I I I always
wonder I know you didn't make this beat
but I know you were very heavily a part
of the process of this album the [__]
you mean beat was insane yeah were you
like when you first just heard that beat
that beat is so crazy and that sample in
that beat just that had to be cuz I can
only imagine like as a producer you
probably hear a beat every once while
you're like [__] I wish I made that one
yeah for sure for and that had to be one
of those but he was kind of like
hesitant about the song really oh yeah
super hesitant like and I was like bro
this is hard like you need to put this
put this on he like you think so I'm
like yeah cuz we was locked in and I had
to go back to Atlanta for like a week
two weeks or something like that and
came back and he had it done and he was
playing me just like all the new stuff
and he played that but he was down there
F to skip over it and I'm like what's
this he played it and I'm like yeah this
is hard and he's like you think so I'm
like bro you you need to put this in
comparison to everything else you need
to put this out like right crazy yeah
dunk Rock that's that's my man dunk been
working for a long time no for sure he
was sitting outside the studio in like
2019 with a big ass sign I remember that
went viral yeah that's the guy yeah
that's me recording the video oh I
remember that yeah yeah that's that's
dunk Rock like he been grinding for a
long time and like he would come to all
the events producer events in Atlanta
and and La anywhere so I've been him for
a long time so when I found out that
that was his beat I was more so happy
excited about it yeah like oh this is
this is bro like and then when it start
taking off it's like you know I like to
see that bro like if you working and you
doing you grinding like stuff that's not
normal you're not begging and it works
for you on that type of level like I was
more so happy for him that's super fire
uh you're working on like a compilation
type project yeah yeah my album yep who
who else going to be on your album uh
nobody want to just confirm right now
you know how that [__] go you know but
it's it's definitely exciting is
definitely something that you never
heard of and it's going to put a put a
pole inside the world of what my music
sound
like okay you know what I mean flag pole
a flag pole okay I was thinking it for
stripper P first n no no
you everything all
right we got to leave here go to the uh
hey want to give a shout out to our
family at King Palm baby want a shout
out to King p man they've been holding
this down for a minute now and um I feel
like my life kind of changed once I
started smoking out of King Palms
because it's so smooth man it's organic
there's no tobacco no nicotine it's a
natural Leaf uh and the best part about
these King Pals they come in so many
flavors this is the latest flavor that
I'm on right now it's the pink lemonade
now it's dope it's a turpine infused tip
you get to stuff your flour in it light
it up you squeeze that tip and you get
hit with a burst of flavor and it is
smacking all right so let me tell you
about King pom we' hooked up to hook you
up if you go to King pom.com right now
you can order anything from the website
if you want a box of these if you want a
grinder if you want an ashtray if you
want some of these you know I mean
whatever you need some of that Lemon
Haze you know I know the holidays just
passed but you like that pumpkin cream
pie they got that too all right whatever
you need it's half off half off 50% off
when you go to King pom.com and use the
promo code bootleg 50% off not to
mention if you're in town you're driving
around wherever you're at I don't care
where you're from where you're watching
this from go to the 7-Eleven they got
King pom go to your local smoke shop
they got King pom the industry leader of
Natural Tobacco nicotine free smoking
experience and trust me when I say you
got to [__] with them bootleg is the
promo code at King pom.com get half off
also want to give a shout out to odd
Soxs can we get some odd
Soxs look at all these [__] odd Soxs
we got here oh my
God first of all the modellos are hidden
all right so look if y'all don't know
man odd Sox just celebrated uh their 10y
year anniversary I was out in Tampa with
them they're our family they're are are
just our dogs for real for real and um
they are the most comfortable socks in
the
world Listen the most comfortable socks
in the world if you guys ever see me
anywhere
I'll always have these on or the white
version of the basics to me these are
like walking on clouds and if you're
into I don't know
Monopoly you know I don't know maybe you
are you're a [__] a Pez guy who the
[__] a Pez guy uh SpongeBob maybe
you're an alcoholic maybe you like beer
so much so I'm first of all I love these
Modelo socks they're fly as [__] all
right uh I don't know which ones I like
more Corona Medela I think I'm going to
go with the Modell sockss and I think I
like Modell more than Corona um
Bubblicious man um how about the Power
Rangers whatever you're into they got it
I mean look WWE
cocacola uh Doritos uh I mean Godfather
they got all the licenses all right odd
Soxs is changing the game the most
comfortable socks in the world I want
you to try out some odd Soxs save 20%
right now don't forget they got the
underwear too save 20% right now when
you go to oddsocks official.com
and use the promo code
bootleg and uh we want to say shout out
to them and congrats to their 10y year
anniversary our partners our family at
odd Sox oh these are gi. Joe draws I'mma
take these home let's get back to the
interview are obviously uh the bouncer
records doing its thing but like what is
like what's what's the plan when you
dropping more music after this uh the
bouncer or the bachelor The Bachelor
record yeah yeah Bachelor um what's the
plan what it say one more time it's been
the record's been out for like when's
the next record dropping I mean been out
for while we we trying to drop like
springtime okay um and really like catch
those spring going into summer months
it's going to be something you know fun
and um I'm just trying to weigh it out
right now and see what I want to use my
catalog is is nuts at this point you
probably got like so many songs Just
sitting in a so many ain't even in the
word you know what I mean it's like so
many times times six you know what I
mean but I just want to I just want to
make it make sense at this point like
these days uh timing is everything
um outside of Gunner who's another
artist that you would love to do like a
full body of work with cuz that's in
again I feel like yeah I was just
telling Ace that about cord I'm like bro
like back in the day like it used to be
one producer right you know what I'm
saying and that was like the nas days
and the 90s and all that like it was
well well not nas he was one first itel
it felt very curated it felt very like
even if you're not getting every like
like you know it felt like the albums
were were moving in sonically cuz it was
one sound yeah exactly so like it it we
got to get back to that to that point I
would love to do that with a lot of
different people um I work a lot a lot
with with Rody and I'm doing like his
next project right now oh really yeah
how's it sounding cuz we're
waiting incredible Rod's an alien people
people don't understand Rod's a [__]
alien yeah yeah yeah he he different and
it sucks because like I feel like please
excuse me for being antisocial came out
in December of
2019 and then the pandemic hits the box
is the biggest song in the [__] world
and like he really really wasn't able to
like fully enjoy what that's like with
the world open like for real like I mean
obviously he went on his tour right
before the pandemic started yeah but
like Festival season was out for him y
you know what I'm saying that whole
project and you know he is for he's a
literal antisocial guy like he's an
introvert like people think it's like a
gimmick or something it's not no we like
one and the same like we talk He he'll
be telling me stuff I'm like bro I I do
the exact same thing but he's an alien
like he's so good like yeah he's fire so
so you're handling a lot of his new
project yeah yeah yeah I'm I'm helping
him pick out all the songs and like do
the track listing so that's somebody I'm
that's like a good friend of mine you
know what I mean we've been locked in
for some years just on some some brother
[__] just having conversations not even
about music so with this is like I
really want him to win yeah me too man
he's a great kid yeah for sure that'll
be hard um for you man uh I always say
there's a few ways to go about the pub
game right because it is a very
interesting side of the game if you're
an upand cominging producer sometimes
taking a pub deal too like too early
could [__] you up but sometimes taking
it too soon can also help you out cuz
they put you in a bunch of sessions and
[__] that might not have happened for
you like what would be the advice you
would give in terms of how to navigate
the pub world as a producer or a
songwriter I man I still got notes about
the difference between um C- publishing
and admin inside my phone to this day
yeah from just reading articles and
teaching myself on what's the difference
in being able to make a calculated
decision I didn't take a co- deal until
like two years of success you yeah
because for people who don't know like
an admin deal is very bare minimum
they're handling kind of they're
administrating it yeah they're they're
they're handling kind of the grunt work
of your Pub yeah a c-pub deal they're
fully Partners on your publishing for
either for perpetuity which you
shouldn't sign never uh or like a 10e
period or whatever the period is Right
10 years is too long but whatever it is
um so yeah so there are differences for
that but like for you like what what
what made it make sense for you to do a
c-pub situation eventually the the the
money you know what I mean and where I
was at in my life and in my career I had
already did uh uh uh admin did and was
making money and it was cool and I was
able to live but it was my situation you
know what I mean and when the
opportunity came it's like all right
cool we going to take this you know what
I mean and from that I was able to pay
my grandmother's house off take care of
my mom take care of myself you know all
of these different things that I that I
always dreamt to do the opportunity came
and I did it so I say for anybody like
the young guys the older guys or
whatever it is it's like you got to
really understand what these things are
first and then make a calculated
decision don't cuz there's not a one
true fits-all situation for everybody
every Everything could be different for
everybody like different situations
might work for you wherever you're at in
life or your career vice versa so yeah
so I always say like just educate
yourself like the more you know about it
the easier to be able to make a decision
when somebody does come cuz they always
come you get a big song you getting call
from everybody you know what I mean and
it's it's whatever it's going to be
whoever you comfortable with but you got
to know what you doing it's going to
happen if you catch one it's
everybody yeah and you got to you got to
know what you're doing so what about uh
for you like uh because I notice some
producers once they get a lot more
successful your time your band with
becomes like less available for making
beats how much of your time do you
allocate to still actually like cooking
up on the laptop or in the studio like
bro it's early as hell I just left the
studio yeah you know what I'm saying at
like 600 this morning wow it's like a
job you know I don't treat it like a job
because I'm living my dream but I still
you know I'm still a hustler I'm still
out here and going to the studios and
going from place to place and you know
taking over the room and letting people
know that I'm here and I'm I'm available
all of this different stuff so I I I
would say all my time oh that's dope
yeah cuz some people like feel like they
get on they start popping and then they
got little mini producers under them man
that was like
but their tags on it and it's like read
the credits you know there's 13
[__] on this you know oh my God
I that's the worst bro that's I mean and
like some producers that's what they do
and they don't they don't deny that
that's what they do and I get it you
know as I get more into this game and
understand what it's about you know I
get it so it's not no shade on nobody
but for me it's like you know I look up
to like the Quincy Joneses of the world
and you know the the the Dr Drees the
people that were if you was going to do
that it was going to sound incredible
mhm and it was going to sound like them
and it was going to be their sound right
you know what I mean so you can't do
that and then you don't make a sound
like turbo has a sound turbo is a super
producer turbo is like you know you can
it's like a for real beat and
it's everybody knows his sound without
it even having to be a tag on it so if
you're not doing that then you just
cheating I guess who's on your Mount
Rushmore of producers all time hip-hop
only hip-hop strictly hip-hop so take
Quincy out of my mouth you got to take
yourself off as well you can't be on
there yeah I wouldn't even put myself pH
on Mount Rushmore yeah four of them four
people
um Timberland for sure for
sure
um Timberland for for
sure I would probably have to
say not even probably Z
toin for sure I love Z toin that's huge
fan of Z toin um Justice League oh I
love Justice League gonna have to put
them all on one head
yep and then you say a four one
more damn you killing me
only hip-hop only
hip-hop Dr Dre Dr Dre yeah Justice
League so hard Justice League is crazy
BR like all the raw [__] I always wanted
to I always compare like my circle and
The Playmakers to like a mixture of
Justice League because it's real music
and it's real U
compositions but like the the Trap sound
of like 808 Mafia right that's fire I
always wanted to like comb those yeah
you know what I mean and make it into
like a thing cuz Justice League had like
cinematic yeah like you be like huge
songs that sh sound like a [__] like
a
movie yeah like a soundtrack for sure
like that's I always say Ross always got
the best beat my I still listen to it
today bro like like Ross's ear for Beats
is like a [__] up there man all time
that's another that's another person I
would love to work with like on some
whole project of just locked in [__]
like I love Ro
do you ever go on YouTube and type in
your name type
beats never have you ever like had
anything like where you've heard your
[__] like cuz there's actual [__]
fake Metro booming beats out there like
with the tag on it and everything are
there people bootlegging your Beats of
course you know does that happen like
where you'll like someone will hit you
up like yo we have a song together and
you're be like I didn't make that beat
bro that shit'll pop up on my on my
Spotify you know what I mean and it's
like you know turbo produced this and
this I never heard of this guy or this
song you know like however you do when
you plug in the songs I don't know how
they do it but yeah that happens all the
time and people call me and say yeah I
got this pack from such and such from
you uh and I don't know if it's real or
not you know what I mean and it's like
well you got to pack from who so if it
pops up on your Spotify how do you take
care of that you just you just have I
call Ace hey call Spotify get this [__]
taken down hey do your thing you know
what I'm saying this [__] ain't right no
cuz I was talking I was talking to
Southside and I was like bro you know
you know how many struggle rappers in my
life for the last 10 to 12 years have
come to me and said that they got 808
Mafia beats dog oh and he was like I
know bro the tag because the thing about
the 808 Mafia is there's like a lot of
Affiliates and then I take that tag and
then dog like bro I got the tag
everybody got the tag everybody has the
tag like you know what I'm saying this
was a thing in a producer Community yo
yo who you got on the app man we got 808
Mafia who who from 808 Mafia right right
it be Kush King from
Mafia that [__] so funny I was like that
[__] would frustrate the hell out of me
cuz you got such an iconic tag like man
you just can't put that [__] on anything
yeah you can't just but I mean like like
I said it's not always about the tag
because you also know when you when you
hear Bachelor it's like H this first 5
Seconds soon as it comes on you like
what is this who is this so I I always
try to get that wow factor it's not that
then it's not a turbo beat yeah what was
it like uh being in the studio with with
uh Savage and Metro booming working like
just recording that
project um bro Metro is a dog bro he
been a dog you know what I'm saying
since and you're just like forever
running Pro Tools the whole time hell
yeah that shit's so fire I'm telling
them like I got beats you know what I'm
saying like but you know they ain't
really he was s he wasn't really
listening at that time but just to see
him work and see how it went like it was
dope and then see the success that came
from it that was super dope just to to
watch the whole process but yeah like I
think it's like a vice show that came
out like welcome to Atlanta or Atlanta
music or something like that I remember
that I watched that yeah I'm in there
cuz I think they went and saw the Migos
too during that time when they was when
they was doing the Savage sessions I was
in all of those just sitting in the back
so it's it it for me at that time it was
like being able to see it at like one of
the highest levels on some Modern [__]
not on some like you know old school old
school [__] you know what I mean so it
was it was definitely dope it definitely
helped me change the way I thought about
things and like how much time and energy
I was going to put into it and and you
know I just took that and ran with it
how inspiring is it for you to be
someone who's working on your debut
album as a
producer and then you see Metro boom and
put out heroes and villains and it's
like to me the best version of that
that's ever been done ever yeah I mean I
don't think any compilation album shout
out to khed I love khed shout out to
everybody nobody who's ever done that
has ever done it even close to that
level to that level yeah it's
cohesive it's just it's like a perfectum
yeah like and and and to be able to
watch it
firsthand and see how much time he put
into it and you feel that when you hear
it you're like oh this wasn't just like
let me just get the hottest
[__] throw them all together
and put out a project no this felt like
Blood Sweat and Tears right right right
right I mean it's it's it's
I can speak for every producer out there
it's like super inspirational it's one
of the reasons why I'm not getting
frustrated with my album and contining
to do it because TR the process yeah I
watched him like do this for two or
three years and then when it came out it
was like oh wow this what you was doing
all this time yeah no it was [__]
amazing body work well hopefully we get
you said Springtime you're going to drop
more music yeah yeah yeah uh like once
it starts getting like March sometime we
we're going to drop the next single and
see how it feels about the album but I'm
working on so many projects right now
I'm not in a super rush how um how close
is the Rotty [__] from being done uh I
don't know if he want me to announce it
but it's coming now it's coming like a
freight train okay yeah and it's hard as
[__] you know what I'm saying like for
for lack of better terms so yeah I'm
excited about that for real and just to
see him go up for real for sure no me
too man well look I appreciate you
pulling up uh go stream your single
Bachelor it's out now yep I mean [__]
man congrats on all the success thank
you bro my guy turbo boom fire can we
show some love to our family at harden
man shout out to harden man look if
you're in Vegas you got to pull up you
got to say take me to harden right now I
need to go to harden they're going to
take you they're going to get you
situated Harden Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like God
uh sweat it feels it just smells so good
in there it's just oh they got their own
scent they're our family too man so make
sure you follow them online Harding Las
Vegas all right shoot them a follow on
uh Instagram also go to Hardin vegas.com
and when you're in Vegas make sure you
pull up to hardine baby